my name is Karla I'm here to talk to you
today about how you can tell stories
with traceroute so let's stop with what
traceroute even is in the first place so
it's a networking tool you can find it
in both UNIX and in Windows though in
Windows it has a different name and it's
a way of showing the path that your
request takes through a network and how
long it took to get to each stage of
that network you can think of it kind of
like breadcrumbs right if you're going
on an adventure to that your destination
you leave this trail of breadcrumbs that
you'll come back and look at later and
it will show you which path you took to
get there it has some pretty Phobos and
kind of intimidating looking output you
don't need to look at it in too much
detail but we're gonna break it down so
you understand what's actually happening
here
essentially this is a tracer to
github.com mostly because it has a very
informative set of host names but if you
break it down line by line there's four
pieces of information for each step the
first piece of information is the hop
number so this is which router you're at
the second is the host name of the
router the third is the IP address and
then you get three different latency
measurements which is how long it took
to get to the router three different
times so you can see whether this high
variability and if you want to
understand the path that your request
took through a network what you really
want to look at is probably the host
names and IP addresses so if we take a
look at just those in this tress in this
trace you can see the path that we took
in this case from Sydney Airport to get
to github so we started off going
through a local router it's probably a
local router because it doesn't have a
host name defined then we go through
Focuses network which connects from
Sydney over to San Jose you can see that
in the different host names root and
then from focus we go to tea leo which
is an interconnect network provider that
goes up the west coast and finally we
make it to get home and this is kind of
really cool because I can see that my
connection from Sydney goes through San
Jose to get to Seattle which isn't
necessarily immediately obvious and is
super useful if you live in Australia
because if my internet goes down I don't
necessarily know which part of the
connection between me and a server in
the u.s. is actually broken looking it
over here we can actually see with those
latency measurements where we make the
hop across the Pacific so the first two
steps are very fast only about two
milliseconds to get to them but by the
time we're at the third is taking 200
milliseconds to get there that's because
it turns out that crossing the Pacific
takes a while even at the speed of light
and I use this a lot because I don't
know
know if it's my Wi-Fi that's broken or
my internet that's broken or the link
between Australia and the u.s. that's
broken or just the server on the other
side there's a lot of things that could
go wrong so that's how a traceroute is
meant to be used it's meant to be used
this debugging tool like why did my
packets go away but back in 2013 I read
a super cool story about a network
engineer called Ryan Weber and he
actually lives in Boston and back in
2013 there was some pretty bad
snowstorms and he was bored and he
really likes Star Wars here's any one's
not familiar with Star Wars it's very
famous for having this crawl text at the
beginning of each film that gives you a
narrative background and it's kind of
slow you slowly get to read the story of
what's happened in the background
context for the movie so he decided that
he would build this but with traceroutes
and this is pretty cool because if you
look at it you're getting like 270
milliseconds and it takes a little while
for each line to appear so it does
actually kind of seem to crawl up the
screen and I thought this was the
coolest thing ever so I wanted to build
my own but the problem I had was what
I'm gonna looked up how he built it
he's a network engineer so he has access
to like commercial-grade routing
equipment and he had two different
routers bouncing these packets between
them so that he could print this out I
wonder my arm but I do not in fact have
access to commercial grade routers for
my side projects so I wanted to see if I
could build this in the cloud with a
single stop but that meant that I needed
to understand how routing walks on the
Internet
so at a high level this is the
traceroute we saw before you know we see
a lot my laptop connection going to a
router then through focus and till there
it's a little bit zoomed out and then I
want to github but this is kind of more
like what the internet looks like right
it's very interconnected it's very
unclear which path you should take
how do we know which path we should go
down in order to get to get home
well it's kind of like being lost in a
foreign country but without your phone
either it doesn't have data or it's flat
or it's the 1990s and so you're trying
to get to a friend's house you don't
know how to get that so maybe you ask a
friendly stranger hi here's my friend's
address how do I get to this location
and they say ah I don't really know
exactly where that is but that's suburb
Oh to get there you need to take the
train to town hole she do that take the
train to town hole and you get off the
train ask the next person hi trying to
get to this address do you know how to
get that
to say I'm not sure exactly where that
is that's Street you want to walk north
to get there you keep doing this until
you actually get to your friends house
that's what's happening with internet
routing my laptop doesn't know how to
get to get help but it does know the
gate hubs on the internet and the best
way to get to the internet is through
the router the router also doesn't know
why github is but it knows that it's in
the US so it takes the bogus path Lucas
doesn't know where it is but it knows
it's in Seattle on the most way to get
to Seattle start elia and then Celia
doesn't know how to get to github so
that's what it chooses to do and this
all works fantastically assuming there's
no loops but you can see that we could
run into some troubles if focus and
Tilia disagree on where they think get
help is if focus thinks it's on the East
Coast say because they think it hubs
West Coast data center is down and Celia
thinks it's on the west coast we can end
up with this loop and then our packets
and requests are just gonna kind of loop
around forever and get stuck so the way
we solve this is by adding what's called
a time to live counter and this is
literally just a number on every request
you send that gets decremented with each
hop so it might start at say 64 when it
makes it to the local router will
decrement it by one because that's one
more step and we'll keep doing this and
if we ever get to the point where the
counter reaches zero and we haven't
gotten to where we want to go we'll send
a special message called the TTL expired
message back to the person who sent the
original request and this basically says
look you said to try for like five
minutes and it's been five minutes and
it hasn't got that so I'm gonna give up
now so let's go back to those
breadcrumbs let's say you want to have
breadcrumbs of where your request has
been but you don't want to have to
implement anything special in the
protocol to get support for this how
could you do this well you can imagine
that you can send a packet to get help
but set a time to live of zero it's
gonna make it one step and immediately
the route is gonna be like I'm all out
of like I'm a lot of time I'll send you
back an expired message cool so then you
can print that the router who sent you
that expired message was the first step
then you'll send the counter with one
this time you'll make it to focus one
step father
print the message and then print that
you made it to focus we'll do that for
till here as well and then when we get
to github we'll get a normal response
back so a print that we made it that how
long it took and then we'll stop
incrementing that Council and that's
actually how traceroute box but since
traceroute itself is a hack
I can abuse it with my own house so
rather than sending TTL expired messages
just if I get a pack up with the TTL of
zero what happens if I also send it for
any packet that has a TTL less than a
certain amount say the amount we want to
pretend that we're farther away by so
concretely if I got a request like this
time to live is zero when it gets to me
but it the packet was destined for me in
the first place so I should really be
sending a normal response but instead
I'll send a TTL expired response then
when I get a response with a TTL of one
this time or request with the TTL of one
this time I'll actually send a normal
response to tracer it looks like this
happened those is one extra hop along
the way and so it's gonna print out one
extra line looks a little bit like this
if you implement it in like pseudocode
Python so we see to duplicate lines in
there and we can obviously add multiple
steps and we can spoof who we send that
TTL expired message from to control the
IP addresses that we see in this output
and that's all very well and good but we
said will them tell stories and stories
I'm told with numbers they talk with
watts which means we need human readable
names on these not just IP addresses the
way traceroute is defining the host
names on those each of those steps is
using reverse dns which is like
everything else in this talk a hack on
top of DNS so DNS is very simple it just
lets you map a host name to an IP
address that's how we resolve names on
the internet but let's say that you
wanted to know given I've got this IP
address which hostname does it go back
to that's not immediately obvious
because it's a one-way lookup what we
could do though is DNS is this call
property that for a hostname you can
strip off any prefix and you'll get to
like a broader source of truth basically
so if I want to know who earns Collard
oh I oh I can strip off the color and
just stop just ask who owns bio they
should know who owns color dot IO so if
we want to do this for IP addresses we
could hypothetically reverse the IP
address stick a special thing on the end
and then do exactly the same mapping
which is what reverse DNS does it's a
total hack on top of DNS because it's a
total hack that means there's no actual
protocol requirement that those two
things match
I can set the reverse DNS record to
something totally arbitrary and not only
can it be totally arbitrary it doesn't
have to match the for pointing record it
can also just not be a valid hostname at
all which is what we've done here so if
we put it all together basically we're
going to do is buy some IP addresses
that you control set reverse DNS on them
to whatever you want I recommend doing
this with providers that are less strict
some providers like Amazon say that you
have to have a fold pointing record but
do you find a really sketchy hosting
company don't have to worry about that
even with the really sketchy hosting
company I managed to find who would also
let me buy IP addresses and not stick
them on like stick machines on them
still cost about $3 for each one so that
means they're essentially each line if
your story is gonna cost three bucks a
month kind of expensive this is kind of
what it ends up looking like and now
since Julia's thing is beefy let's do a
demo so live this is from a server
actually in San Francisco because my
other stuff is in San Francisco and it
kind of just speeds things up we can see
that we make it to the Palo Alto
internet exchange that and then there's
this huge long wait because Amazon
refuses to return any information so we
have a bunch of steps that just go
missing and wait a little bit longer and
there you go
[Applause]
so that's how you can use a single Sava
and a bunch of IPAs to tell your story
[Applause]